this is why the pro-abortion movement
now is doing everything they can to
avoid talking about abortion itself
that's why they're saying that the dobbs
case which could overrule roe v wade
it's not really about abortion it's
about contraception it's about
uh the obergefell redefinition of
marriage it's about interracial marriage
oh yes if you if we get rid of roe
versus wade they're coming for your
interracial marriage what are you
talking about
find find me one conservative in the
country who has said that
you can't they're all they're trying to
do is distract and now what they've
settled on especially in in the light of
the buffalo shooting
now that they're exploiting a mass
killing up in buffalo a few days ago
they're saying that really the pro-life
movement it's all about white supremacy
this might be the most ridiculous
argument of all
it's hard i mean it's hard to pick it's
hard to pick which is more poisonous
cyanide or arsenic you know which is
more ridiculous the arguments about life
are the arguments about white supremacy
but this is what they're saying there is
a prominent twitter account uh goes by
el norte rieda
i don't know what her real name is
she has a phd
she's a published author she's got a big
old platform she's got a blue check mark
and yesterday she posted onto social
media she said the majority of people
who get abortions are white overturning
roe v wade neutralizes two major threats
to capitalist white supremacy the
declining birth rate and the shrinking
white minority criminalize abortion
ensure a future majority white working
class
okay
she posted
a little infographic here to back up her
claims
the infographic
disproves her claims she says the
majority of abortions are are of white
people
the the infographic she posts says race
of abortions 39 white so right off the
top this woman doesn't even know what a
majority is majority is 50 plus one
the a plurality of abortions are of
white people fair enough and she says so
if we get rid of abortion you're
disproportionately gonna have more white
people in the population so let's look
at let's just look at those statistics
she says
according to her graph
39 of abortion patients are white
28 black 25 hispanic six percent asian
pacific islander three percent
other
i am so glad that you have watched my
content that you listen to the things
that i have to say something tells me
the political powers that be
do not necessarily want you listening to
the things i have to say or watching
this kind of content surveillance is
increasing people have your data okay to
protect your data from being tracked i
would urge you to get expressvpn it does
not matter where you live every time you
search for something online you watch a
video you click a link it is all getting
tracked by three letter agencies in the
government by big tech or by both they
can match your activity to your true
identity using your device's unique ip
address when i turn on expressvpn they
can't see my ip address at all my
identity is anonymized by a secure vpn
server expressvpn encrypts 100 of my
internet data for protection from any
eavesdroppers or cybercriminals i go
online i click that button it takes two
seconds and then i'm protected i don't
need to worry about it stop handing over
your data to the government and big tech
companies defend your rights with the
same vpn that i use and trust
expressvpn dot com slash michael noll
show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-w-l-e-s-s-h-o-w to get
three extra months for free or click the
link in the description below so the
plurality of abortion patients are white
39
but 62 of the country is white
28 of abortion patients are black
only about 13 of the country is black 25
of hispanic patients of of abortion
patients are hispanic something like 18
of the country is hispanic
meaning
abortion
disproportionately kills hispanic and
especially black babies
white babies are relatively
underrepresented in abortion if you
overrule roe v wade and then if you go
further to criminalize abortion the
effect will not be
disproportionately more white babies it
will be disproportionately more hispanic
and especially disproportionately more
black babies the infographic she's
posting the statistics that the
pro-abortion movement is using proves
the opposite of the point that she
thinks she's making this is the best and
brightest they've got folks if you were
on the fence about abortion
i think you can fall off the fence now i
think it's pretty clear which side has
all of the arguments and all of the
truth and it's all coming to light
and it makes me feel really good almost
as good as my ex chair go check out
x-chair today
what this is coming down to
especially in the light of the
the midterm elections especially in the
light of the democrats looking for
anything to try to gin up their base
they're losing on the economy they're
losing on immigration they're losing on
foreign policy they're losing on
inflation gas food
go down the list the democrats are
underwater so now they are going back to
their most basic strategy they're trying
to gin up racial resentment
and this has worked for them for a long
time and they're tying it into this
abortion issue there's a woman
uh joe louiseman
never never heard of her before but
she's apparently got a podcast and a
fairly big platform
yesterday she said quote
i would rather get an abortion than have
a brown child who ends up being adopted
by white evangelicals
it is not a kindness to children of the
global majority
global what does that mean she just
means not white people
she's another obviously
that includes
black people hispanic people asian
people all sorts of people
and and even within that to say asian
right you're talking about what a
quarter of the world's population or
more but so we're talking about what
japanese chinese indian does that guy
all of these people they're just she's
just saying when she says global
majority she just means everyone but
white people just don't like it is not a
kindness to children of the global
majority
to give them to people who will
traumatize them with self and ancestral
hatred
and abortion is an act of love
imagine hating white people so much
so much
that you want to kill your children just
despite white people
that's what we're talking about here
obviously it goes without saying
if you said this about any other race
you would not only be deplatformed you
would be socially ostracized if your
employer found out you would lose your
job if your school found out you would
be expelled
you might be prosecuted
we still have pretty strong speech
protections in this country they might
find a way to prosecute you
if you said i would rather my child die
than be raised by a black person
or bring in the
religious aspect here i'd rather my
child die than be raised by a muslim or
something you you would be
totally booted out of society and yet we
are told that it is white people and
christian people who have all of the
privilege
of course that's not the case the only
the only groups that you're allowed to
discriminate against legally
are
white people in race
men
in sex
and
straight people i guess if you talk
about sexual desire
and
christianity bears a fair brunt of it in
the public square it's the it's totally
the opposite of what people are saying
and
i suspect they actually don't see it
i suspect that their hatred has just
driven them crazy anger and hatred and
wrath can drive you crazy
obviously crazy this woman is saying i'd
rather kill my kids than have my kids
raised in a loving home
by this race that i hate
white people by this religious group
that i hate christians
hey there i'm glad you liked that clip
now what is required is that you ring
that smash that like that hit that
subscribe do the
hit the gizmo do the thing you get the
notifications also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michaelmoles show leave
a five star review maybe more if you
feel so inclined we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you